انه عام التحولات في السياسه التركيه جمله
من المتغيرات في ثوابت انقره السياسيه
والثابت الوحيد في منظور تركيا
لاعداء دائما في السياسه تركيا مستعده
لنقل السيطره من مناطق تواجدها الى النظام
حال استعاده الاستقرار السياسي وعوده
الامور الى طبيعتها في البلاد هو تصريح
لوزير الخارجيه مولود شاويش اوغلو في
تعليقه على تقاربه بلاده مع دمشق
بلاده مع النظام السوري ستمهد لحل سياسيا
وفق قرارات الامم المتحده يضمن عوده امنه
للاجئين مؤكدا استمرار تلك الاتصالات
المتحده
وروسيا والعراق والنظام السوري مستمره
تقارب انقره مع دمشق تمخض عنه لقائه وزراء
دفاع تركيا وسوريا وروسيا في موسكو بحضور
رؤساء مخابرات الدول الثلاث كاول لقاء
الرسمي بين مسؤولين اتراك وسوريين منذ 11
عاما
في اطار قرار مجلس الامن رقم 22 54 وبهذا
المعنى فاننا نعتبر ان الاعمال التي سيتم
تنفيذها في الايام المقبله
ستساهم بشكل جيد في احلال السلام
والاستقرار في المنطقه وسوريا
المسلحون الاكراد في صلب مفاوضات دمشق
وانقره وجودهم قرب الحدود يؤرق تركيا التي
هددت بشان عمل عسكري يستهدف مناطقهم المهم
بالنسبه لتركيا خلال الفتره الحاليه هو
ابعاد الخطر الكردي عن حدودها هناك خطوه
اخرى متعلقه باللاجئين خط على عنها الرئيس
اردوغان قبل اشهر وهي التفاهم باعاده
هؤلاء اللاجئين الى سوريا قبل الاقدام على
الانتخابات
العامل الداخليه هو الفيصل والدافع الرئيس
لانقرا في تقاربها السريع مع دمشق وفق
محللين فورقه اللاجئين التي تشهرها
المعارضه في وجه اردوغان باتت تشكل تهديدا
لمستقبله ومساعده في كسب الانتخابات
التاليه
دائما في السياسه بات عنوان الاستراتيجيه
الرئيس التركي خلال الفتره الماضيه وكما
يرى البعض ان كل الخطوات السياسيه خلال
العام الجاري والاشهر القادمه انما تهدف
الى ابعاد الناخبين عن صناديق المعارضه
وجذب الاصوات الى الاعتناء في الحاكم
زيدان زنجلو العربيه اسطنبول